question j'ai ri merci laurent merci à
tous ça va être dur en 18 minutes on a
essayé vous propose un un sujet
l'histoire des sciences commandes pour
quoi pour qui alors comment je vais
passer vite
il faudrait beaucoup plus de temps pour
quoi pour qui on va voir un petit peu et
je vais m'intéresser surtout à rôle que
peut avoir l'histoire des sciences dans
une prise de conscience citoyenne des
problèmes de la science et de la
technologie aujourd'hui et de ses
implications
alors on a relativement l'habitude de
considérer que les scientifiques doivent
se doivent de vulgariser leurs travaux
leur science leur recherche et leur
application ce qu'ils font en général et
on voit en général aussi dans ceux de
voir des scientifiques deux utilités
essentiels cse n'est indispensable
d'abord évidemment faire partager à tous
ou du moins aux curieux les avancées de
tous les champs de la connaissance et du
savoir
et justement moi je suis chargé de
mission à la culture scientifique c'est
pas pour rien et les politiques de
diffusion de la culture scientifique
aujourd'hui son sont énormément
encouragé et elle vise à faire en sorte
d'atteindre une espèce d'idéal ou les
curieux se serait en fait toute la
population c'est à dire rendre tout le
monde curieux de sciences et deux de ses
avoirs
et puis le deuxième la deuxième utilité
c'est faire voir tout autant les progrès
engendré que les risques encourus
éventuellement sur les applications qui
sont faites des découvertes
des scientifiques alors là les
scientifiques devraient être aussi des
allemands des lanceurs d'alerté
ça peut être le cas et si on pense aux
dangers que représente aurait ou
représentent déjà entre des mains mal
intentionnées
les actuels progrès de la génétique des
nanotechnologies en particulier on sait
que ça arrive très vite des nouvelles
technologies et des outils puissants de
contrôle des individus
cela permet évidemment il faudrait que
les scientifiques et cette conscience et
soit aussi quelque part des lanceurs
d'alerté de manière à ce que la
population puisse participer à cette
réflexion et la question ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui comme en témoigne par
exemple cet ouvrage paru en 1973 je
dirigeais par lévy leblond desjobert
avec cette phrase un énergie nucléaire
manipulations génétiques technique
raffinée de contrôle social le débat sur
la signification sociale de la science
loin de s'éteindre dans la monotonie
temps devenir de plus en plus la sphère
de tous donc des vannes date pas
d'aujourd'hui
il était très présent dans les années 70
effectivement
et puis j'ai mis sa petite phrase de
pierre bourdieu en fin de carrière quand
il s'engager dans dans des mouvements
solidaires la liberté des chercheurs est
un mythe et la neutralité scientifique
n'existe pas donc autant de phrases qui
qui interpelle aussi les scientifiques
et le leur image dans la société alors
nombre de ces scientifiques se prête au
jeu de la vulgarisation
selon à peu près un schéma que voici
il ya la zone sérieuse des scientifiques
bien représentée par ce portrait
d'einstein à gauche et puis la zone
d'amusement c'est à dire nous tous dans
notre bac à sable et les scientifiques
sont censés apporter
disons une vulgarisation via tous les
médias qui sont indiqués là-haut et
d'autres vers différents types de
publics comme vous voyez le public formé
aux disciplines scientifiques mais pas
forcément spécialistes les publics
curieux de science qu'on pourrait
appeler public averti et puis tous les
publics à savoir les citoyens et ce qui
se passe très souvent c'est que les
alertes et la prise de conscience
citoyenne sont en général plutôt le fait
de personnes qui appartiennent à
d'autres champs disciplinaires
disciplinaire ou à d'autres réseaux que
l'essor ce que les chercheurs qui
vulgarise leur science souvent les
chercheurs vulgarise leur science et
c'est tout l'alertent et souvent apporté
par d'autres en particulier les
journalistes les sociologues les
philosophes des politiques des
intellectuels de tous horizons des
célébrités du monde des arts et du
spectacle aussi donc tout le monde et
lanceurs d'alerté les journalistes en
particulier bon heureusement
qu'aujourd'hui le journaliste en une
approche plus sérieuse et journaliste
scientifique que jean soudain je me suis
amusé à mettre cette phrase à deux ans
dans la revue illustré en 1908 à
l'occasion de l'élection de henri
poincaré à l'académie des sciences
parce que on peut écrire aussi de très
belles choses sur la science sans y
comprendre et simplement pour faire un
exercice de style comme vous le voyez
est à côté des de ses autres
spécialistes que les scientifiques
cherchent eux mêmes on a vu émerger
grâce aux nouvelles technologies
évidemment la puissance de nouveaux
outils de communication une autre
population parfois incontrôlable et aux
informations non vérifiées mais souvent
utile de lanceurs d'alert à savoir les
individus lambda qui se mobilisent pour
pallier justement la carence en
informations du monde institutionnel en
la matière et c'est comme ça que ces
personnes parviennent général sur
internet à la convaincre politiques
parfois les chercheurs de l'importance
de pousser plus avant des investigations
sur des effets possiblement néfastes que
telle ou telle avancée scientifique ou
technologique
on peut penser par exemple à toutes les
alertes sur les ogm sur la nocivité
éventuelle des téléphones portables etc
c'est souvent ce sont des individus qui
ne sont pas issus des réseaux dont je
viens de parler mais quid de l'histoire
des sciences là dedans alors c'est
volontairement que je n'ai pas cité les
historiens des sciences dans la liste de
personnes que je viens de donner même si
je sais qu'ils jouent souvent un rôle
indirect puisque en faisant de
l'histoire des sciences
il nous raconte certaines choses qui
nous éclairent sur sur à la fois les
avancées et les dangers que cela peut
représenter si on n'y prend pas garde
l'exemple classique par exemple est
celui de la découverte de la
radioactivité
un historien des sciences qui vous
parlera de l'histoire de la
radioactivité vous dire à tous le bien
que ça a pu apporter mais aussi tout le
mal qu'on a pu en tirer dans certaines
circonstances et le et que ça peut
dégénérer
donc quand ils vous racontent cette
histoire il vous alerte quelque part il
ya une vigilance qui est sollicité et
ont souvent on cantonne souvent pourtant
l'histoire des sciences à des utilités
rôles objectifs bien définis
entretenir la mémoire collective des
origines de la genèse de et des avancées
des savoirs
cela peut d'ailleurs permettre aux
scientifiques d'avoir une attitude
réflexive sur leur propre science au
sens où l'on tend à edgar morin et
s'éteint une des approches essentiel de
l'histoire des sciences servir la
pédagogie parce qu'on sait que
l'histoire des sciences est sollicité
dans les cours scientifiques à tous les
niveaux et qu'elle peut permettre de
débloquer certaines situations c'est les
apprenants que ce soit des élèves de
du secondaire même voire du primaire et
des étudiants je suis bien placé pour
savoir s'il enseigne des mathématiques
et je sais que très souvent pour
débloquer certaines situations revenir à
l'histoire des concepts montrer comment
ça s'est construit au fil du temps et
bien les étudiants sont surpris et ça ne
les aide à mieux comprendre ce qu'on
leur enseigne
et puis fournir aux chercheurs
d'aujourd'hui les textes anciens souvent
oubliée et qui peuvent débloquer des
situations on remettre au goût du jour
des méthodologies des modes
d'investigation que l'on croyait
dépassée ça arrive très souvent et j'en
ai aussi l'expérience j'ai fait
numériser le premier journal de
l'histoire des mathématiques les
analogies ordonne au début 19e et à
cette occasion j'ai des mathématiciens
d'aujourd'hui qui m'ont sollicité sur
certains articles pour avoir plus
d'information etc et qui ont réinvesti
des articles qui date de plus de 200 ans
dans leur recherche de aujourd'hui donc
c'est c'est aussi un des rôles de
l'histoire des sciences
je donne donc alors évidemment on a
aussi la puissance par rapport à ça des
nouveaux outils
donc je donne ici deux exemples de sites
celui dont je viens de parler en gros
une dame point org
non pardon non
l'essentiel c'est ici d'accord rue c'est
l'habitude de ce qu'elle voit par
exemple un exemple c'est une dame
numérisation des archives de
mathématiques c'est un programme du cnrs
qui numérise absolument toutes les
archives de de pratiquement tous les
temps en mathématiques et qui est un
outil fondamental
donc c'est des historiens des sciences
qui étudie ces documents départ et c'est
un outil fondamental pour les chercheurs
d'aujourd'hui et puis un autre
notre lien ici plus grand public le
passé que je vous conseille d'aller
d'aller regarder parce qu'il est tout à
fait passionnant c'est bine une
bibliothèque numérique ce sont des
textes fondamentaux de l'histoire des
sciences qui sont numérisés mis en ligne
avec des analyses de chercheurs
d'aujourd'hui et ses destinées à tous
les publics et c'est tout à fait tout à
fait passionnant voilà donc voila voila
un des rôles de l'histoire des sciences
aussi là je cherche mon bar en bas alors
quid aussi du rôle social de ces
spécialistes de ces historiens des
sciences et bien l'histoire des sciences
fourmille d'exemples qu'ils soient
peuvent nous alerter sur les dérives
possibles du présent en regardant les
dérives du passé
soit nous éclairer sur certaines
distorsions idéologique sur certaines
imposture scientifique et nous rendre
vigilant car sur les mêmes
problématiques
aujourd'hui est donc ça c'est censé nous
faire prendre conscience aussi où il est
possible ça ne fasse prendre conscience
aussi de la possible émergence d
imposture scientifique donc qu'ils
peuvent avoir un impact dramatique on en
verra tout à l'heure une plus
philosophiquement de la relativité des
connaissances
scientifique de la respectabilité des
modèles et des théories là je convoque
un philosophe autrichien karl popper et
tous ces travaux sur conjecturer
réfutation de la prévenance parfois à la
limite du dogmatisme des paradigmes très
fort qui s'impose dans dans le milieu
dans les différents domaines des
sciences et là c'est le philosophe
américain historien des sciences aussi
thomas skoun qui a très bien décrit sa
dans sa structure et révolution
scientifique mais encore les vices
cachés des règles même de la
reconnaissance de la science à savoir
des règles institutionnelles et là ce
sont les sociologues des sciences qui
ont bien montré c'est ce problème alors
on a en france
et puis un article qui fait référence en
la matière c'est celui de nos robert
merton qui date de 1940 de ces normatif
traction york times
voilà donc on voit que l'histoire des
sciences déjà peut alerter sur ce genre
de problématique
et si nous prenons en revanche si nous
prenons un exemple récent d'un ouvrage
paru
las ces derniers mois alors je ne dirais
pas excellent parce que ce serait
manquer de modestie j'ai participé pour
un chapitre mais un ouvrage d'historien
des sciences sur leurs méthodes en
histoire des sciences
et bien si nous le parcourant cet
ouvrage nous nous rendons compte que les
problèmes que je viens de soulever à
savoir le rôle de l'historien des
sciences le rôle d' alerte d'information
de du public généraliste est très peu
représentée n'est même pas abordé
véritablement même s'il y a un chapitre
de michel blé qui est excellent sur
peut-on comprendre la science en
l'histoire et on se doute bien que non
et puis deux chapitres l'un d'eux
véronique le rue à quoi sert l'histoire
des sciences et l'autre de patrick
petitjean sur l'académie interne
internationale d'histoire des sciences
et les problèmes éthiques que sa pose et
vu les régimes en place à l'époque 1900
en 1940 donc ce sont des des chapitres
qui aborde ce genre de sujet mais sans
en parler au présent c'est à dire sans
montrer le rôle des historiens des
sciences possible aujourd'hui
et pourtant alors j'ai peu de temps pour
développer des exemples historiques qui
permettrait de montrer le sceptre ce
rôle que nous peuvent jouer les
historiens des sciences et qui
appellerait à une vigilance sur les
frontières entre entre science neutre et
objective et sciences entaché
d'idéologie d'intention et donc je vais
me contenter de relier rapidement les
questions soulevées par les découvertes
récentes dans le sens de la génétique
je vais les relier à l'eugénisme de la
fin du 19e et du début du 20e siècle et
de façon connexes 2 imposture
intellectuelle qui s'y rattachent
voilà j'ai même reste devrait alors
quand à la force des paradigmes qui qui
oriente les sciences et frôle parfois le
dogmatisme je n'ai pas le temps d'en
parler et je renvoie à la lecture de ce
de cet ouvrage de thomas secoue la
structure des révolutions scientifiques
qui le présente très très bien alors
arrêtons nous un instant sur l'exemple
de l'eugénisme de l'eugénisme à l'adn
j'ai intitulé ça alors ça nous renvoie
il ya le choix
sur internet j'ai voulu rester connecté
si vous voulez à certains sites qui
aborde ce genre de sujet et là ça nous
renvoie à ce site
de l'encyclopédie de l'agora au québec
c'est une encyclopédie participative un
peu dans le genre
wikipedia mais qui est tenue qui
convoque des scientifiques reconnus pour
des contributions très étayé très
documenté et en même temps des citoyens
qui viennent apporter leurs commentaires
sur sur les fait exploser alors je vais
me contenter j'ai pas présente et où le
site alors là par exemple vous avez sur
le sujet qui est que je suis en train de
vous proposer
vous avez vous avez j'ai pas l'habitude
d'un je travaille pas sur ce ce modèle
une conférence ici sur l'eugénisme que
vous pouvez aller regarder sur ce site
sens aussi bien géré simplement prendre
un raccourci sur le même site
voilà un raccourci d'un article de jean
claude guillebaud sur sur justement la
tentation de l'eugénisme à la fin du 19e
et au début du 20e siècle
alors qu'est ce qu'on a retenu de
nausées nisme c'est ce qu'ils dénoncent
dans cet article on n'a retenu que
l'utilisation qu'en ont fait les nazis
oui et c'est ce qui a fait que
historiquement c'est même devenu un mot
péjoratif quelquefois alors que c'était
une science au départ on oublie que
l'eugénisme avait été une doctrine
absolument dominante dans les pays
anglo-saxons et en france aussi et qu'il
y avait eu des politiques tout à fait
tout à fait que j'aie nist
tant que je pourrais en citer l'huile en
cite quelques unes des politiques de
d'élimination de certaines catégories de
population de sélection et c'est aux
états unis en angleterre en france et
donc c'est l'historien des sciences se
doit de rappeler que l'eugénisme ce
n'est pas que ce qu'en ont fait les
nazis
ce qu on en retient habituellement mais
c'est aussi tout un courant de pensée
qui était très en vogue est très
dominant et qui avait déjà impliqué des
réformes et des politiques précises en
matière de santé dans les pays dans les
pays occidentaux à l'époque alors
voilà pour cette question donc si vous
voulez c'est peut-être utile à rappeler
aux citoyens que nous sommes surtout
comme le signale guilbault nous sommes
loin d'être assuré que ce schéma ne se
reproduira pas et on peut voir que il se
reproduit c'est ce que montre guilbault
à travers certaines politiques
oulala ça est alors vite vite licence co
et cyril burt
bon là aussi c'est sur un site canadien
que je ne montrerai pas je vais passer
directement à la faire lyssenko sur un
article sur le même site en revanche
voit la morgue lyssenko pendant 30 ans
l'agriculture soviétique a été dirigée
par un fou alors ne regardez pas trop le
texte il un peu partisan avec des
expressions pas très scientifique entre
guillemets et qui a fait du désir
scientifique une religion d'état et qui
a imposé des réformes je peux des
réformes sur toute l'agriculture
soviétiques qui ont généré une famine
considérable et des dizaines si ce n'est
les centaines milliers de morts sans
parler de tous les concurrents
scientifique qui l'a fait éliminée pour
avoir pour occuper la place qui
voulaient occuper bien et alors une
autre affaire qui est plus problématique
et qui montrent mieux encore le désolé
mais je n'arrive pas à faire apparaître
la barre en bas voilà qui montre mieux
encore le lien qui peut y avoir avec des
problématiques d'aujourd'hui c'est la
faire ça eric woerth voit la série dirt
donc c est considéré comme un grand
psychologue britannique hylas il a été
même à n'oublie pour tous les travaux
qu'il a fait il a fait des travaux sur
deux sur l'intelligence et le cuit il a
comparé le devenir intellectuelle de
jumeaux monozygotes séparés à la
naissance vivent dans des milieux
culturels très différents et c'est des
tas de statistiques et où il a donc
montrer que l'intelligence était innée
et que et donc il a influencé les
politiques éducatives en angleterre dès
les années 1940 1950 et on a sélectionné
des tas d'enfants on a mis des barrières
par rapport au cuit justement sur la
base des travaux de lyssenko bon et puis
il s'est avéré qu'on a démontré plus
tard que c'était très certainement une
vaste imposture intellectuelle déjà il
était difficile de trouver autant de
jumeaux homozygotes séparés et vivent
dans des milieux différents
il faut arriver à cumuler toutes ses
propriétés c'est pas c'est pas donné
et ce qui est intéressant donc il ya des
travaux dans les années 1970 ce qui a
été fait et qui ont montré qu'il y avait
visiblement
visiblement imposture mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que cyril burt
est toujours à l'ordre du jour si on
regarde par exemple un site très sérieux
le gall tony site ute qui est un site
bricks and britannique chercheurs qui se
présente ici un rien le kaltene
institute avec les gens reconnus c'est
un institut qui travaille avec
l'académie britannique etc etc et qui
vous allez le voir
viala secours de sahil woerth et tour
des questions on peut juger idéologie
comme c'est trop et sur voyez les
profits le génie qui sort sa note et
donc qui fait l'historique de cette
polémique a posteriori sur les travaux
de serrurerie burke et de cette possible
imposture et qui dit que finalement non
c'était pas une imposture c'était juste
quelques écrits de fin de vie de sarah
burke intitulé plus trop vigilant sur
l'aspect scientifique de ce qui est
publié
mais qu' il faut tenir compte de ses
travaux qui sont toujours d'actualité en
matière d'intelligence et que quoi qu'en
pense la société les journalistes
engagés il est logiquement politiquement
etc
et bien c'est toujours d'actualité et il
est toujours nécessaire de considérer
que les enfants doivent être
sélectionnés sur la base de leur
intelligence ine donc vous voyez que
l'histoire des sciences en la matière
sur la base d'une imposture peut nous
éclairer aussi sur ce qui se passe
actuellement et sur des idées qui sont
défendues actuellement et qui peuvent
avoir un impact social politique très
important sur les sur les sociétés voilà
j'aurais pu vous aurez vous le détailler
davantage évidemment mais je n'ai pas
trop le temps je termine donc par un
petit clin d'oeil pour conclure après
est ce que les historiens des sciences
se doivent de participer à la science
spectacle on peut se poser la question
mais enfin c'est une très jolie
couverture de sciences et vie sur des
événements absolument bouleversant bon
et c'est vrai que en filigrane il ya des
questionnements scientifique enfin là
c'est de la science spectacle
et puis se méfier des idées reçues et là
on peut penser que les historiens des
sciences justement peuvent avoir un rôle
à jouer auprès du public des citoyens
pour qu'ils se méfient des idées reçues
en science et la recherche on avait fait
la une sur des tas de sujets très variés
on sait science mais vous regardez tous
les sujets qui sont qui apparaissent on
fait rentrer tout ça aussi dans le sous
le chapeau science voilà donc vigilance
informations l'histoire au service du
présent c'est peut-être aussi un des
rôles des historiens des sciences c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de démontrer très
rapidement je m'en excuse ici et je vous
remercie